Prepare for a film that only exists so non-nerds
will recognize the blonde guy in The Avengers.
You’ve seen great superhero films.
You’ve seen terrible superhero films.
Now prepare for a superhero film that’s
just kinda ehhhh.
I mean I guess they did the best they could
adapting a comic book about a bratty space
god.
"You are an old man and a fool!"
Journey to Asgard, the land of viking myth,
where
everyone gets a pointy hat,
the gods live inside a CGI pipe,
and the only way in or out is through the
Rainbow Road level from Mario Kart.
Meet Thor, the least relatable Marvel hero
since Dr. Strange.
He’s an idiot demigod prince, with a magical
hammer that really needs
to buy a vowel.
“Mjolnir”
“Mjolnir?
What's Mjolnir”?
But Thor isn’t the only god in town...
Meet Loki, Thor’s evil stepbrother, who
will stop at nothing to betray
his adopted father
with the help of his real father
"I will conceal you and you can slay him where
he lies."
in order to betray his real father
"And your death came with the son of Odin."
to impress his adopted father.
"I could've done it, father.
For you!"
Ugh, that makes even less sense than his plan
from The Avengers.
"Not a great plan."
Meet Odin, Thor and Loki’s dad who pretty
much guarantees that one of
his kids will grow up to resent the other...
“Only one of you can ascend to the throne,
but both of you were born to be kings."
Oh and all of these rejects from Lord of the
Rings, Game of Thrones, and Xena: Warrior
Princess.
Struggle with the former god of thunder as
he’s stripped of his powers and banished
to these two square blocks in the New Mexico
desert.
There, he’ll acclimate to our strange Earth
customs like...
ordering in restaurants,
"Another!"
health care,
"You're no match for the mighty --"
traffic safety,
and horse purchasing.
"I need a horse!"
"We don't have horses.
Just dogs."
"Then give me one of those large enough to
ride.
Watch as Thor turns to Jane Foster for help,
a brilliant astrophysicist with supermodel
good looks that just happens to be single
and who immediately falls in love with Thor
for no good reason.
Make that 6 reasons:
Aaaaabs.
So ride along with Thor as he loses, then
regains, his magic powers,
hooks up with Jane,
saves two different realms from destruction,
and learns the virtues of patience and humility
...All over the course of a long weekend.
Seriously.
This whole movie takes place over two and
a half days.
Starring...
Thunder From Down Under
Lokimon
The God-Father
Eye Dress Elbow
Lord Zedd from Power Rangers
1 Broke Girl
and Portmandia.
Thor...’s obligatory movie
So Loki “dies” at the end and comes back
to life by the ending credits?
That’s gotta be some kind of record.
Hey, Screen Junkies!
If you like my voice, how about clicking that
big subscribe button then, huh?
Also: want to see Lucius Fox himself read
The Fox?
Then click the box to the left to see us waste
Morgan Freeman, Robert DeNiro, Michael Douglas
and Kevin Kline's time reading dumb stuff.
Speaking
of which...